I have a report now that they are
sending a new role of rover to mars and
we are responsible for doing one thing
which is programming the algorithm
inside the rover which checks if numbers
are prime because let's say our Rover is
communicating using RSA it needs an
algorithm inside that can do a prime
ality test now when you design a rover
or anything to go into space you have to
be very efficient in every way so the
components used have to be very light
the amount of power every subsystem uses
has to be minimal you have to be saving
energy and mass at every point in the
design process so we have our work cut
out for us because we have to be able to
deal with numbers up to this size and it
has to do it very fast so if we give it
a very small input let's say just 90 it
should be able to calculate that almost
as fast as this entire number so as the
input grows we don't want to see any of
this noticeable slow down now I want to
analyze the user questions or the ideas
users have had which were really good
from mathematical standpoint we are
checking if n is prime or composite so
given some number n think of the space
of all possible ends as say if n is a
hundred then this space is two to a
hundred and what our algorithm is doing
is its searching this space ok so you
can think of algorithms as searching a
space and at each point it's asking
think of it as a step right a primitive
step it's asking a question and it's
actually a composite test the question
so say this is a we're at number a we
would say in the trial division method
is n divided by a we just try this we
drop a here and we try pen devise a and
we see if the remainder is zero which
means is a divisor of n then we can say
aha we know one hundred percent we
raised the flag or
one hundred percent sure its composite
otherwise at each step we aren't quite
sure it might be prime but we're not
sure so we continue searching until we
hit the end and remember our wall in
this case was at the square root of n
that's at the worst case that unit
situation occurs when we ends prime we
searched all the way to the square root
of N and then we can say ah it is prime
and no more on one hundred percent sure
so in the case where n is even a
multiple of two prime so 7 times 7
equals 49 if we throw 49 into our
algorithm it is the worst case occurs we
go all the way until the square root of
n so the first set of questions from for
example the fourth dimension asks once
we rule out to as not divisible then all
multiple two of two could be ruled out
the same for 345 etc so that's a really
great point our old algorithm was
stepping along one at a time but we
could be using patterns we know about
composite numbers such as we know for
sure that if a number is divisible by 2
then its composite if it's greater than
2 so tues prime but then we can say oh 4
is composite 20 I missed five here sorry
about that 4 6 8 10 and instead we can
take is step like this 3 5 7 9 so one
category of questions they all try to
reduce this space so if we eliminate all
the even numbers now the check space
instead of being up to the square root
of n is the square root of n divided by
2 and we can find other patterns and
composite numbers to try to make this
even smaller the other type of question
concerns the case where we find a
composite witness that is we find an a
that allows us to say oh we know n is
composite Lola said wouldn't leaving the
loop as soon as we find prime check
equals false
down on some of the time and yes that's
totally correct and it's something we
want to do as soon as we are searching
along using some step defined by
whatever pattern we're using we find a
composite witness that means it passes
our test and we say one hundred percent
composite we should halt early we stop
and say up we're done we won't continue
searching and this halting early is
great except that doesn't have to help
us in the worst case which is if n is
prime then the early halting won't help
us and now we can visualize how these
improvements allow us to reduce the
space thus preventing as many checks
happening inside the computer which
depending on our computer will reduce
the amount of time it takes so now I can
show you the visualization I've set up
below which allows us to compare two
algorithms based on how many steps occur
during their execution on the left is
algorithm a which is trial division
which checks from 2 to the square root
of N and on on the right is algorithm B
which is let's just say our improved
algorithm and in this case I've applied
the check if it's divisible by 2 so we
only do it half as many steps and I also
terminate early in this algorithm B so
it's not perfect I've just applied a few
user modification so we can see what
happens and now I'm going to just play
with us to show you it here we can see
as I scroll we see algorithm a we have
the output whether it's composite or
prime and at the bottom you'll see the
number of steps so the first thing to
notice is on the right hand side every
other number takes only one step and we
know why that is because if it's an even
number such as this it will quit so our
old algorithm took 314 steps and our new
algorithm only took one step because it
checked if it was divisible by two so
that seems like a really nice
optimization however as we build our
input
you'll notice the steps increase and you
look the bar grows and turns red once we
hit the region when once we approach the
region where we're going to crash so
this red line up here is step limit if
your bar hits there we fail which means
our Rover would break and in this case
the browser will actually crash so I'll
try to get close to it so I'm close to
it now and it's running very slow I can
feel that my browser's just about to
crash and give me the circle of death
but notice that their improved algorithm
took only two steps in that case but
remember the worst case so i'm going to
i have a few large prime numbers saved
here for example we have to be able to
handle any case we don't know what we're
throwing at our algorithm so if i throw
a large prime at it look what happens
algorithm B as we know is taking half as
many steps in the worst case but it's
still taking many steps here because
it's the worst case right so we're
getting close to crashing here and this
is not a very long prime we're still way
under 15 digits and when I put this 12 I
think this is a 12-digit prime into our
algorithm let's see what happens it's
lagging it's maybe it's going to crash
look what happened both algorithms went
way overboard so it didn't work our
improved algorithm is not good enough
yet but now we have an understanding of
what we're trying to improve which is
number of steps in the worst case and we
also have this cool tool which allows us
to visualize how fast it's growing how
fast the number of steps grows as our
input grows and below I'll explain how I
set this up so you can set up your
algorithm and compare it with the base
case and see how much better you can do